Mr President thank you for joining us
how are you
I'm well I'm strong as I want people
sometimes a little bit sad when we have
some attacks
and each day proud of our soldiers in
the Wawa Army and of course first of all
I'm proud of our people
almost a year ago
the start of the war
could you tell us what you remember
about the night that the Russians were
coming
foreign
[Music]
person
foreign
like I said to you already that from
that period from those days this day
is
began this long day how close were they
to you some suggestions they were just
two kilometers away
um
[Music]
enough foreign
foreign
here we are almost a year later and um
we're hearing about tanks you need tanks
you need them fast a deal is being done
this week what can you tell us about it
is
Russia
only
um foreign
thank you
foreign
breakfast
[Music]
thank you
but chunks are coming
Abram tanks are coming from the United
States and finally leopard two tanks are
coming from Europe you must be relieved
uh shiny
ah sorry counselors
um
foreign
[Music]
the tanks could be here from Europe soon
but the tanks from America may take
until August is that too late
too late
but but I I I don't know really I don't
know real situation for now for this
minute when they will be when they when
America uh uh will give us Abrams and
and I don't know
I don't know really where I'm from
Europe will come tax for example we had
decision with macron and I'm thankful
for him I think he opened the new page
yes when he made the decision to give us
thanks
I didn't remember it was two weeks three
weeks ago we had a phone call and he
accepted that that is a decision I was
emotionally I was very positive but I'm
not two weeks the president of Ukraine
in war yes so I understand what does it
mean it means that they will come and
still we didn't get them of course
because training missions and it's a you
know
that's why
who knows when the tanks for example
leopards to will be in Ukraine who knows
it nobody knows for today of course
we'll know in some you know days in some
weeks but but totally that is the big
problem
you understand
um foreign
[Music]
virtually
is it fair to say I'm I'm sorry
about this
yes
thank you foreign
would it be fair to say Mr President
that that emotion from Germany has cost
lives in Ukraine
this War and who takes our lives
especially Russians it's not Germany
these were it's not about Germany not
about France not about
Britain not about everybody not about
USA all these Russians narratives that
this word that means that USA fighting
on the territory of Ukraine with Russia
or NATO is fighting that is their
narratives it's not mine because it's
not truth I have no narratives because I
think that this more short way to the
people to society just to speak very
very honestly and pragmatic and so I'm
I'm very honest and pragmatic with
Germany I am really thankful for
decision but if it's about
some tanks don't give us that's true but
emotionally it's not it's not correct
that they take the lives of our no no of
the opposite thing I don't know if it's
right in English and I'm worried sorry
and and that's why so I I think that
they support ukrainians so many people
of our ecpt because of this war a lot of
our refugees are now in German and they
help them so that is important
let's talk of a Russian surge coming
soon
when do you think that might be and how
prepared are you
um
foreign
[Music]
I was very privileged to meet your wife
recent me when she came to London and
she when we were talking there was an
aeroid siren next to your son's school
she was obviously very anxious when that
happens she's she's a mother she's not
the wife of the president and you're a
father
not just the president leading your
country in war
um
War rips families apart a lot of young
Russian boys are being sent to their
deaths as cannon fodder what's your
message to their parents
foreign
[Music]
I do want to ask you a little bit more
about your family I also want to ask you
about your relationship with Boris
Johnson but before that may I ask you
about peace talks Mr President under
what circumstances would you consider
peace negotiations
[Music]
foreign
if you can't sleep at night and are
alone with your thoughts do you ever
wonder what might happen if you were in
a room alone with President Putin would
that help at all to resolve this war
pretty interesting for me
not interesting to meet
not interesting to speak
yeah why because we had meeting with him
in Normandy format it was before the
full-scale invasion
I saw
the man who said one thing and then did
another so for me I I can't understand
is it his decisions or somebody else
so who wrote me to meet what to shake
hands don't be interesting
to speak don't disagree I I really don't
understand who really make decisions in
Russia
sometimes I think their society they
push on him and he has
he doesn't has his own
decision
sometimes I think that is his I think
close people
sometimes close business or oligars
that's important for for them to take
some part of Ukraine because they see
something for their future
so with whom I'm speaking
not interesting from the moment I I was
interested in
after 2014
when they occupied our territory and
occupied the donbass I was interested in
when I became the president to see him
to meet with him to have decisions to
deoccupate our territory by diplomacy I
was interested in I met I met with him
and after that I made you know tense
100 phone calls to different leaders
like I like I I did this time but only
the difference that I previously I I
made the phone calls and said that it
was before fuscale Invasion I said the
dangerous situation
he doesn't want to speak I can't
understand please make some you know
some meetings let's make the diplomacy
steps
nobody I made calls to Moscow
and I couldn't understand why why they
don't speak
is it too late now
too late not interesting who is he now
after full-scale Invasion for me he is
nobody
nobody no decisions with him not
interesting somebody who is a somebody
to you is Boris Johnson
um would you like to see him have an
official public role as a UK Envoy to
Ukraine
Embassy he will be ambassador from
Britain in Ukraine it was pleasure
I was pleasure he's a good guy and I'm
I'm not I'm not sure that he's ready for
such status because no but who knows I
mean that to his pleasure was pleasure
really how would you feel if he ran
again to be prime minister would he get
your support
I think that it's not correct to me to
support Johnson to be a prime minister
when
rishi's prime minister is not correct
I'm sorry totally the policy you have to
understand my opinion is really it's
really my opinion that the society
and so support teeth and so supports us
so I'm very thankful and all my
appreciation just to Britain and to to
your to your people to society to Great
Britain all the all all the regions
really they made they made a lot and
really helped and so I and it was by
letting Johnson and the to now now if
I'm speaking about now we have good
relations with sunak I think
we had more long relations with Johnson
because it was more long time and of
course
and of course very difficult time and
the first days of full-scale Animation
that's why I I saw Johnson in different
situations I saw him in not in war and
then in full-scale war that's why we
have special relations
um talk to me about your family your
family life you talked about them having
to leave just before when the war was
breaking out you see them very rarely
I I think the question is to my family
am I am I good
my like Father the attitude to me I
think it's also not
um I don't know if I can use such word
not polite to speak about me to speak me
about me in such case but I I think that
they love me
and it's not about thinking I feel it I
think these feelings is the best one and
I want to save it yes and that is the
most important I have
so my my family how often do you manage
to see them how often do you mind
oh bath
uh
often my wife then my children it's a
it's a bitter that I can see my children
you know once per
now now it's often than from the very
beginning last two three months we have
we have once per 10 days
I can see my my children one for two
weeks I can see
have some food have some talks and I can
I can see my daughter because she's
she's a student
from this year and that's why I I often
see her than my son he smoke guy
he's just young he's just young he's
he's 10 years old what do you talk about
wolf I'm I'm I think I I I'm listening
talking he's he's he is so good he is so
sweet and and he's 10 years but he's
thinking like
a strange strategy uh tragedy for all
our families I mean that through Ukraine
because all our children adults and all
of them they speak about war they speak
about when we will win they know it
exactly it's better then they know uh
better than me I think when you will win
yes they they will win tomorrow and it's
about our children and they know
everything you know about what's going
on we need tanks what the chancellor is
waiting we need we have to push we don't
have F-16 we have to push them so it's
very interesting
I I mean that but it's interesting and
from one side from Another Side like I
said to you
it's tragedy that they
they speak about it not about children's
not about their you know games between
each other not about soccer yes no no
dialogues about soccer no that is the
difference
but we will we will change this
situation I think can I ask you about
your previous life when you were an
actor and a comedian
now you're a wartime leader how do you
bring that sense of humor that you
undoubtedly have
to your colleagues in order to keep up
their Spirits I I never I never lost my
sense of humor I think when people lose
it they lose up
the quietness yeah
um the state of mind
yeah I think so
yes you have to to concentrate and be
very serious not during monthings
you have to do it in very important
moments in very difficult decisions you
have to be worry you have to be clever
and you have to be adequate and you have
to be brave because you are the leader
that's it it's very important it's not
interesting what you feel you have to do
it and you have to change if you feel
that you can't you have to change very
quickly not to run stay change and make
decisions that is very important and
very important to make decisions quicker
than enemy that is that is very
important not to think it's not about
philosophy or something like like you
know like like this you have you have to
make decisions I think that is steps to
the big victory small steps small
Victoria steps small steps each day each
day you have to you know wake up and
think what we'll do today
to make this Victory closer that is very
important and that's why but to be a
decree you have to sometimes you know
yes in the night I have some you know 15
minutes to think about to speak with
children by phone something like this to
to to to to
not without any crying that it's so
difficult and very huge to lead the
country without all these things it's
it's not I think you will find some
people who will tell about you like in
in you know social media Etc yes without
them without it you have to be strong
and that's why humor uh sense of humor
shows
when you can joke shop sometimes of
course it shows that you are okay that
you are strong that you control the
situation
it's very important to control the
uh that's it nobody can make decisions
without you
because then the result so I mean that
the result depends on you yeah so that's
why you have to concentrate and humor
makes you
human
when's the last time you laughed was it
my outfit
oh not one second ago I think last time
yeah and let me let me ask you this um
it's your birthday today yes happy
birthday it's it's not funny
I'm 45 it's not funny what would be the
best gift you could have
the best gift I don't I don't I don't
really I don't like I mean that
I had everything before my presidential
time and before this war and so I I will
not be surprised if we are speaking
about some things you know some material
materials are some material things it's
not interesting yes so
of course of course if our soldiers can
today deoccupate some little little
village it will be great because it's so
it's so difficult it's so difficult like
they go 100 meters 500 300 and then 300
back and then 500 forward so for me the
best present the best present is walking
forward
that's it thank you